as many of you will know the Vietnam War
was mostly fought in one Vietnam South
Vietnam which had to deal with
incursions from its northern neighbor as
well as Cambodia and Lao throughout the
war The Saigon government was primarily
aided by the United States which kept
the overwhelming majority of its
military efforts in the South but given
that North Vietnam was their primary
enemy why didn't the United States fight
there why didn't the USA invade North
Vietnam so first of all a bit of
background Vietnam used to be part of
French Indochina which along with many
other colonies gained its independence
from France in the wake of World War II
as a condition for its freedom Vietnam
won Independence as both North Vietnam
centered in Hanoi and South Vietnam run
from Saigon shockingly the Vietnamese
people weren't happy with being divided
and it wasn't long until both vietnams
were fighting to unify under their
respective governments North Vietnam was
Communist and this was the Cold War and
so naturally both Moscow and Washington
took an interest the United States
believed that the South was going to
lose eventually and so sought to
intervene to prevent the spread of
Communism but given that invading the
norm would have relief the South and
also if successful would mean that there
would be one less communist nation in
the world why didn't the US invade there
well even though the US didn't send
troops into North Vietnam they did bomb
it a lot however in spite of the United
States freedom to use its air force over
North Vietnam it never launched an
invasion of the country for several
important reasons the first and primary
reason was China the U.S military and
government remembered that in the Korean
War when U.S forces pushed North into
the communist state and towards the
Chinese border Beijing soon got involved
and the Chinese government was quick to
remind the United States that if it were
to move against Hanoi China would send
troops to directly intervene and this
threat now had much more weight since
China had just fallen out with the USSR
and thus it was believed in Washington
that China was serious since if it
failed to follow through it would no
longer be seen as a serious communist
state as such it made the most sense for
the United States to adopt the strategy
of defeating the northern Vietnamese
forces within the borders of the South
the second reason was domino theory this
was the idea that should a stateful to
Communism it would influence its
neighbors to do the same thereafter thus
the American strategy was is only to
prevent the further spread of Communism
not to use military force to topple
already established Marx's State the
fear being that if already existing
communist countries felt that their mere
existence was grounds for an invasion
many may have asked the Soviet to
Chinese nuclear protection which as
previously established had the potential
to cause problems and also the American
government was much less optimistic when
it came to the outcome of the war whilst
many believe that North Vietnam could be
defeated there were few that believed
that communism in the north could be
eradicated this was primarily because
many in both Vietnam's Associated the
end of French Imperial rule there with
the Communist resistance that said there
were those in the military that believe
risking war with China was worth it this
didn't happen because Congress wouldn't
have approved the resources and Manpower
necessary to do it and also because at
this point the president was busy with a
thing for some though it seemed like the
only way out America was kind of Trapped
At this point it couldn't Advance
leaving all of the momentum with the
North Vietnamese forces but it also
couldn't withdraw because doing so would
be admitting defeat to a communist state
and would also leave an ally to be
conquered and so after a decade of this
the United States had to accept that the
cost of helping South Vietnam was too
high and so in 1973 after the US had
signed an agreement with the north
stating that a totally wouldn't annexed
the South the United States left and
something which was surprise exactly
zero people the north invaded once more
in 1975. and soon the two vietnams were
reunited under a communist government I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker kosher wolf Sky
Chappelle katowitzka Alex Schwinn Adam
Stalter rod D Martin AF Firefly Jordan
Longley Jerry lambdin wire hockey Marcus
arsner Spencer Lightfoot Captain psydog
Marvin Cassel Miss izet kamun Yoon
Winston K wood boogly Wiggly the
mcwhopper Aaron the white Gustav Swan
Maggie Paskowski Anthony Beckett schewed
in spinning three plates Coppertone
Daniel tibian Charles the first and
words about books podcast